what's the um the Top Gun is gay yeah  yeah women from a sleep with me yeah  what is Top Gun it is a story about a  man's struggle with his own homosexual  yeah you wrote that yeah well me and me  and my my buddy Roger Avery kind of  Roger did come up with it first but back  when we were video archives we worked on  it we turned it into a routine it's  because that we did on at Targets we did  it at parties we did it at Gatherings it  was just this routine feels like a stand  it feels like stand-up yeah there's a  whole routine that we did together and  then I was doing a cameo in this fun  little movie that I was doing and I was  just told to pretty much improvise  something okay well I had that routine  ready to go so I just like did it and  like that became a thing uh it reminded  me in a way of when in Reservoir Dogs  when you go on about like a virgin yeah  yeah yeah it's the same yeah it's in the  same it's in the same thing